[Music]
in lefty for life News know how it works
submitted by I will always love take it
but once it left the always a lefty I
trained myself to be a lefty a little
bit that's all though you're always
around oh [ __ ] I did when I had to
browse porn with my right hand I had to
learn how to jack it with my left
speaking of a man chopped up his son's
hand over his porn addiction whoa you
know what's the cool thing about Muriel
she could write with both hands that's
the highest compliment you've ever paid
her in my income in my company yeah so
she she [ __ ] up her wrists I think
like rock climbing or some [ __ ] and then
so she just learned to adapt and then
she learned to write with her left hand
so she could she could write with both
alright fell asleep on my hand when I
was in like tenth grade and I killed the
nerves in my wrist and so for not even
joking right now like for three to four
months my hand was like this and I had
to put it in the cat's just because this
looks ridiculous
no dead serious I had to put in like one
of those it's not a cat serious is you
being color blind
well no no that wasn't bit that what
that was a bit this is like real from
sleeping how do you sleep like this no I
slept right side so I'm Harvey's Libra
but I slept so hard on my oh my hand
like this or whatever just cut the
circulation nerve endings in exactly
well the doctor told me that there was a
chance I wouldn't get it back because
nerves are so weird but he said that
hopefully I would and then all of a
sudden the nerves just woke up one day
oh lucky you yeah thank thankfully yeah
that is but I had to learn to do
everything with my left hand for sure oh
[ __ ] so can you still are you slipping
out okay I'm not gonna lie what country
does this place just take places what is
going on with your mouth right now
things move in India oh [ __ ] and the dad
of the butcher Oh
clean-cut dude he has four children well
what can he check off continue he has
four children too including two sons the
oldest son recently got a smartphone and
he just got addicted to watching movies
and porn and his dad would repeatedly
warned him like you better stop watching
porn I don't know why but you didn't
like watching porn and then finally they
had this really big fight this one night
and the kid was like you know what I'm
running away I'm never coming back
and then the dad was like all right then
fine whatever so then the kid comes back
later when everyone's asleep and then
that next morning both the father and
the son they ended up getting into
another fight and then that's when the
dad was just like I've had enough and
then he just chopped his head makes
sense I'm on the dead side it was
between the wrist and the elbow god oh
that's a poor is he's like no I am
sticking by my decision he [ __ ]
deserved it he's a piece of [ __ ] where
is this again is a kid I don't know do
they have like do they have like
Bollywood style born in India is a huge
[ __ ] like orgy that comes out oh well
[ __ ] that kid though cuz if you ran away
you should have committed your [ __ ]
19 years old [ __ ] you can't come back
that's not your house so technically
you're an intruder what are you talking
about he [ __ ] in his own father
chopped off his yeah but he's an adult
now so he left he said I'm done and he
left and he broke bet he broke into the
house again you sound ridiculous I think
do I real thing is I don't think he cut
off his hand for jacking off too much oh
you dig up dunno I don't think too much
the bandwidth I think he was just
hurting his dad's feelings by being
disrespectful yeah so that's why he's
really now a sturdy firm I don't think
it means yeah you do
it has nothing to do it that is just
disrespectful let me just chop that hand
off Fred yes could you not much so much
porn every day [ __ ] you dad your hand
anymore with your left hand while you
try to disrespect this okay what my dad
doesn't know is I suck my own dad I took
a yoga lesson so I can suck it off oh
yeah how does he know how does it my dad
wouldn't know what hand our girl is yeah
that's true yeah what if he's
left-handed if he's like which hand you
drink it with which one and then he's
like oh this one is like okay then you
know like how do you know yeah that's
true if you found out your son's jacked
off would you get angry no I would just
tell them that you have to do your own
laundry though yeah I would I would get
angry if they're like jacking off so
much snow that they're getting bad
grades they're not doing anything
they're like lazy in like I don't know
it's cuz they're jacking off though
relieves tension but you go to sleep and
you don't get anything done he's talking
about four constantly oh yeah took over
my life come home from school I can't
wait brother go to sleep boy wake up I'm
about to do homework right now you go
through one page making me horny you're
like oh my god the letter three is so
curvy I got a look at some porn susan b
anthony my god a ball I did spottings
[ __ ] making me so anxious always a
part of people in the books I guess you
get horny from that you know or maybe
anatomy book probably did it to you huh
I never studied Anatomy it was [ __ ]
pre-algebra dad kind of sexy looking
ladies in my algebra book you know
they'd have those ladies and heavy
sweaters and like sending to a math
problem or something
I would never punish my kid for
masturbating I would just prefer that he
just do his own laundry from now on and
that his room not smell they probably
have a different culture out there where
he's like do masturbating in India must
be rough cuz it's so hot over there with
most things in India must be wrong yeah
India oh [ __ ] that right a woman in
India her dad that boy no I wish I was a
Bollywood star in India though oh you
should be really light skinned because I
knew the President of India basically
yeah cuz I think like if you're rich
you're real rich like if you live in
those countries and the disparity is so
huge yeah that's like remember that one
guy that made like a huge tower of his
whole family in the middle yeah yeah
yeah yeah and then there's like swimming
pools on the rooftop and all that [ __ ]
yeah like 50-story there's some crazy
amount one of the ships I like watching
on YouTube is watching Indian Street
food vendors cook cuz everybody I do one
thing really [ __ ] well and they do
it's extremely [ __ ] fast now they'll
cut a [ __ ] shallot in their hand and
not somehow slice off their [ __ ] hand
wow so much skill I see that I love when
they make the curry in the street looks
like old [ __ ] things I've said maybe not
as offensive is that I travel and eat
street food all over the world so I can
say that and the funny thing is so okay
so after the club in Beijing right we
ate some [ __ ] those pancake things
from a guy that was pushing a car I all
this [ __ ] the place I get food poisoning
in Asia is when I went to Hong Kong in a
legit restaurant and I had [ __ ]
noodle soup pour the noodles back
leftovers in the [ __ ] ball and then
they serve that [ __ ] back out you know
what my rule of thumb is when I go to
those places if it's not cooked in like
500,000 degree oil I'm not gonna eat it
and actually cooked in front of me so
when I was in Taiwan though I basically
only ate the street food and I only ate
in the morning because that's when it's
fresh they make it right in front of you
and that's
you could ask them for fresh ones too
like if they have like little fish
sticks or whatever and that already
pre-made you can go kind of freshen or
just oh I didn't know that all I know
like street food in Taiwan like once
it's past the morning and then you leave
them alone it's all ask cuz like I got a
couple stuff later on because it's still
open til I get like 4 or 5 p.m.
dude I get a carne asada burrito in this
place we used to live in Koreatown and I
used to walk to that place and one time
I got so sick from after eating has that
place then I was like literally in bed
like I've been there right and then
three days after that I went back so
[ __ ] good I was like it's not their
fault
you have immunity now exactly and I
literally did that and got it again yeah
I did I did because it's so [ __ ] good
and they're so cheap and I had no money
I feel from like food poisoning or
something the first meal I get is always
McDonald's like if I need to solidify my
[ __ ] I always know that I can count on
macdonald it's little fight it's kind of
like you know Deepak sushi right it says
don't want to make sure like you know
it's like it gets nice and firm so you
get them all my [ __ ] and just like I
feel like my intestines are just like
like this is just squeezing and I'm just
throwing it out there I always get the
same [ __ ] street tacos from the same
place every time I eat it there is
there's nothing wrong with them I just
can't really digest greasy foods very
well yeah I still go back diarrhea I'm
good but what was this article about all
right ginger coconut Indian hand killer
yeah yeah well all I know is that that
guy's really [ __ ] [ __ ] up you just
to put it in reality I've never got sick
from street food or like I've even eaten
in like a little [ __ ] dirty ass
village before and then the they just
made like food with their dirty-ass
hands I got a bucket ain't all that [ __ ]
and it didn't get me sick but I have
from restaurants in America when I went
to Taiwan I only got sick once from food
and it wasn't it was from Delta airline
food and I had projectile vomit it was
so funny too cuz like I was like right
in front to where like first classes and
they had that curtain and [ __ ] but I
couldn't make it to the bathroom so I
just ran in and they're like sir excuse
me I was like I'm gonna [ __ ] barf oh
my god and she like
so I'm like sitting there and it's the
first thing I'm thinking is it don't be
too loud just follow you threw up in the
airplane in the first class bathrooms it
sounds like okay like don't throw you
ran in there I ran in there or you in
the air now we're in the air already
dude usually ride where I am like
they'll [ __ ] tap you on the way it's
all hot pale I was I was sweating and
I'll just like in the first thing I
thought was like don't make too much
noise and all I did was this
yeah it was like that's the first time
I've ever had projectile vomit I didn't
know that [ __ ] was waiting yeah it
exists and it was just spawned on and I
was like so [ __ ] like sick I just got
like the one square tissue I like try to
clean up the bathroom have you ever had
diarrhea and vomiting yeah I'm like
sitting on the toilet all you're doing
is screaming as your barfing I'll go
buddy I had kidney stones once and they
got me in the emergency room they're
like sorry I got the way and if the pain
I was in was so not heard those her
kidney stones are a bit that I
projectile vais I started projectile
vomiting and they immediately wheeled me
in there did they have to do though the
[ __ ] thing where they had to break it up
first no they had to give me a bunch of
pain meds and then they had they gave me
this thing to pee it out what did you
get the console's from did I tell you
there's no multivitamins I don't know
what it was cuz I got in twice is it for
energy drinks you think [ __ ] no I drew I
pound these things now back can I have
them there's only thing keeping me alive
what yeah what causes kidney stone
dehydration so it's a classification
that happens and so they're basically a
calcium balls yeah could also get them
from my taking too many multi-buyer
being dehydrated which is man kiddie
stones do cuz I ate those gummy vitamins
a little too much cuz they were
delicious there's a high max amount i
straight-up told my dad I was because I
was laying in there like in so much pain
and the pain minutes hadn't kicked in
yet and I was like dad just pull the
plug let me die
seriously I was like let me die man and
he's like Steven there's no plug to pull
like if you ever get a kidney stuck she
will understand how [ __ ] painful is
to [ __ ] piss a rock out of your dick
yeah it was not God piss it out yeah
yeah it was not nice so what do they do
they break up the stones allegedly and
just you just have it's supposed to
break it up in your system somehow but I
had to pass that [ __ ] and it was nuts
dude this is what happens when you Pete
no like legit legit and to scale by the
way yeah legit mine was like a lot
smaller mine was intact come out of your
pee-pee it just tears shreds it up as it
comes and it's [ __ ] up your
intestines as it's going through it
there's got like razor edges on it it's
not it's jagged ass Bob did you save it
for good luck hell no I was so mad at it
I would have saved it
[Music]
you